[Music]
apples were my favorite fruit growing up
originally came from china but today in
britain we grow over 2
000 different types
[Music]
the most popular eating apples in the uk
are braven and gala
but don't miss out on some of the older
types like the sweet nutty russets
and fragrant coxes when it comes to
cooking apples it's got to be a sharp
brambly
which i'm using as part of my compot for
lunch
now for the apple compote what we need
to do first is to get these peeled
and sliced i get my pan on to get nice
and hot
now let me give you a little taste of
that
they're incredibly acidic okay and you
need to cook them
those wonderful red apples you've got
are called bray burns
what other apples do you know green ones
what they called um
i'm not too sure what the green one is
another word for your nan
grandmas no red
no pink lady apple no
granny smith granny smith apples that's
right
what we're gonna do is cook the cooking
apples
and the eating apples together
i love the combination of the tartness
from the brambly cooking apple with the
sweetness of the braeburn
get the pan nice and hot and sprinkle
the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar three or four nice
slices of fresh ginger
and three little cinnamon sticks i want
you to remember that
because we're gonna look for them okay
because once we've used them
and they've worked their magic i need to
pull them out see all the sugar
dissolving
definitely now we just let that go a
little bit darker
okay and then the place
is quick doesn't it
give that a nice little
toss okay nice golden color
cinnamon in ginger in so
we're cooking down the apples butter in
gently cook until the apples soften then
take off the heat and they go into there
what's that coming out dad so that is a
little bit of the
puree i'll show we'll do that in a
minute how many ginger
four four ginger and three cinnamon
three cinnamon out with a cinnamon we've
got another ginger
gingers and we take a spoon
of apples
it smells so nice how nice is that look
see the coloury apples
let's put these in the fridge to get
nice and cold
that's the compost sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to crown the top
do you separate the egg whites into
there for daddy
all right egg whites are in egg whites
are separated
and i'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
[Applause]
good girl
[Music]
now let's see if you've got a really
nice stiff peak so you lift them up
now that is what i call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad
not bad next in a separate bowl whip
double cream until stiff
nice and slowly
so cream whips so much quicker yeah
nice that by hand we're gonna put some
delicious lemon zest which will make the
cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compot puree
you mix that in nice and carefully so
it's like this
apple butterscotch now to make the cream
even lighter
fold in those whisked egg whites and
sugar egg whites
into the cream just nicely fold that in
so you bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses
yep good girl
silly we're on for a treat open up the
piping bag
now twist the end now you could spoon
this in
but i want to just give a nice little
lift it also gives it a nice
pattern lemon on top
back in the fridge irresistible cinnamon
eggy bread
with quick stewed apples
i've never forgotten i think it was
about six years of age when mum brought
this huge
tray of eggy bread to the table and it
was like wow
man we've died and gone to heaven start
off with a slightly stale bread
four or five day old loaf left over if
it's a fresh bread then it absorbs too
much of the egg so therefore it gets
soggy you never get it fried and crisp
and if you're not gonna use the
breadcrumbs eggy bread is a must
in france they call it pan perdu the
lost loaf
now eggy bread is great on its own but
serving it with stewed apples
is delicious so the secret here keeping
the skins on
it's a lot of flavor in the skin and
also it stops the apple from breaking
down too quickly
they get these nice chunks as opposed to
a sort of apple puree
[Music]
now get your pan nice and hot and
sprinkle a couple of tablespoons of
sugar take the
sugar down to a light caramel it's quite
incredible
how cheap it is to make this and yet it
was so filling
if you haven't got apples this recipe
will work pretty much with any fruit
you've got in
don't be scared to mix a pear and an
apple a banana and a pineapple
just chew it lightly toss in the caramel
get a little knot of butter that makes a
nice
toffee apple flavor really simple
now you can see what's happening the
apples are caramelizing but they're
staying intact because the skins on the
apple
and the caramel's turned into this nice
rich butterscotch sauce
once you've glazed all the apples a
couple of tablespoons of water
in there
bring that bowl and let that cook out
now the eggs
three whole eggs
whisk up the eggs add about four
tablespoons of milk
you want the egg thick and rich
and then lightly sprinkle in a couple of
tablespoons of sugar
that sweetens up the mixture and when
you start frying the bread
it caramelizes it beautifully a teaspoon
of powdered cinnamon
that gives the bread that really nice
spicy deliciousness
apples are glazing beautifully and put
them on a low heat
and get a pan on now for the bread a
teaspoon of oil
that stops the butter from burning
butter in
as that starts frothing get your bread
in
it's going to be pretty quick now now
you don't leave the bread soak in
drain and in the pan
once your egg bread has browned flip it
over
90 seconds each side that butter gives
that nice
golden brown color of that egg
[Music]
beautiful absolutely beautiful
it's quite remarkable isn't it a couple
of eggs splash of milk leftover apples
and all of a sudden you've got this
stunning breakfast
[Music]
now my apples they've all glazed
beautifully
get a nice spoon of that amazing juice
and drizzle that over
mmm wow if my mum saw me doing this
she'd kill me you're getting all posh
again no no
i'm using a touch of iced sugar to make
him look stunning
that for me takes me back to when i was
six years of age
and i thought i just won the lottery
that is incredible thank you brett
you won't get more breakfast for your
buck my mum's incredibly delicious
cinnamon eggy bread
with quick stewed apples
you